it's a very fun movie Anabelle creation
director David Sandberg is following
that James Wan path yeah going from the
conjuring verse to the DC extended
universe James is doing Aquaman while
David is taking on Shazam how would you
describe the tone of Shazam it's a very
fun movie like a fun light-hearted movie
you know because it's about a kid who
gets to become an adult superhero so I
mean that's just good me so fun to
explore
I loved your draft I assume that was a
hundred percent legit oh you saw that
one because some people did think it was
a hundred percent legit
yeah I've lost all faith in humanity is
this going to be I'm assuming we're
going full origin story for a lot of
people this will be the introduction to
such as they have I mean to be honest it
was not a super ear I grew up with
either because he was not when I grew up
in Sweden it wasn't a lot of Shazam
around so it's someone who I've learned
to love later in life as well so I can
relate to that too being nutritious that
which is I think it might be a good
thing that I'm doing it because you know
I know what you need to learn when are
we getting some casting news though
anything you want to share with the
class I can't say something I mean I
feel like et will keep it a
[Music]